[Music]
i believe the people that do the best
nft projects
over the next two years will have
disproportionate
financial outcomes and legacy outcomes
over the next two decades
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
all right everybody so as promised we
have gary vee here to talk about
all things nfts and his upcoming
collection and gary i want you to know
i'm wearing something sparkly for two
reasons
one because nfts are new and sparkly and
people don't understand it so we want to
kind of
explain to people and secondly it's
ramadan and this is made by
designer in the middle east dimayad and
ramadan is about giving so we want to
give people the gift of knowledge
i would love that why do nfts matter and
what is all this craze about
explain it to us it matters long term
because it's a technology that
creates a transparent ledger which
documents
providence actual digital ownership
the actual history of a digital asset
and how it
navigates through the world and as our
society
becomes more digital by nature caring
about things
that we didn't care about 20 years ago
how many followers do we have
what did that mean 20 years ago do i
have a blue check mark on my social
media verified
what did that matter our fortnite skins
our roadblocks
plus ups our nba 2k and madden
cards our other plus ups and mobile
gamings
my 11 year old daughter and all her
friends are trying to buy up
all sorts of things on their iphone
games to show
here's the key to show the world who
they are this is about
identity this is about social currency
this is about the reason and listen i
know the middle east understands this
the way
the americas do people buy expensive
clothes
expensive jewelry expensive vehicles
they take
photos in expensive vacations because
humans
are inherently communicative animals and
we communicate through
our fashion or through our
accomplishments
it is just the way it is and and one can
take a cynical point of view on that
or one can just understand that that is
the human
being i understand that that is the
human being i also
understand that a decentralized
server-based
reality of documenting what tokens you
own is going to be something that will
happen it has happened
we don't need to predict nfts are here
they've been here for four to five years
they are now hitting the kind of social
consciousness
of humanity today much like we focused
on
search engines and browsers in early
internet
today what we're focusing on so far in
early
nft mainstream knowledge is collectibles
and art
yeah that is true that is a part of it
obviously that comes very natural to me
because i am a collector
at heart i am someone who's always been
fascinated in intellectual property
creation
however the far bigger impact of an nft
is the technology itself that token
has an underlying smart contract
potential built into it that contract
can represent
anything it can represent a deed to a
home it can represent
a ticket to a conference it can
represent a vip ticket
to a concert it can represent green room
access
to an event it can represent the fact
that this
image comes with this physical thing you
buy this nft
i must contractually send you this in
the mail i believe that over the next
decade
as people become way more educated on
the smart contract
part of the nft you will see far
more explosion in its everyday use there
is only
a certain percentage of people that are
passionate about collecting
things there is all eight billion of us
that do things that are on a ledger and
are contractually obligated
whether that is to buy something or to
go somewhere and i believe that that
will be what
happens i believe that anybody who sells
a book a music album
access to a sporting event a table at a
restaurant
a conference ticket a home everyone will
use
nft infrastructure in the future decades
thus making this era incredibly
important
because the amazons and ebays and
googles
and microsoft explorer or google chrome
the rules are being established about
the iphone
the early apps there was a bunch of
garbage and there's a bunch of garbage
in nfp land but some of those
early apps became the biggest companies
in the world
i believe the people that do the best
nft projects over the next two years
will have disproportionate financial
outcomes
and legacy outcomes over the next two
decades so for example you're talking
about like this
ticket like let's say for example expo
2020 in dubai or
art dubai or art abu dhabi would they
create an nft like
bring it to life to something that we
would see in the region there will be no
reason for those two events
to issue regular tickets in 2025 when
everybody on earth has this knowledge
the reason is by creating an nft they
create a derivative asset
after the conference so not only that
that asset sits in people's wallets
and just like an airplane ticket sits in
my apple wallet now
over time that token is something that i
can connect to
and do something with for example if we
issued the nft now
two things happen that are better than
the paper ticket or the virtual ticket
that those two events are
issuing today one immediately that
becomes a digital asset
the organization in that ticket can say
if this
piece of art which is a ticket all this
is gonna blend think about the art
festival they can make a very beautiful
digital asset as the ticket when that
ticket
that piece of art is sold in the future
as a collectible
no different than a ticket to the first
world series or the world cup
i can go on ebay right now and buy a
ticket stub from the first world cup
right got it when that's sold the person
that owned it
and ebay will make all the money however
in the future the people that issued the
nft will so for example bringing it to
life
world expo makes a beautiful ticket it's
the actual ticket the nft
when i gary go and i have a lovely time
but then in six years
the artist that made that ticket became
super famous and everybody wants this
nft and i sell it for two thousand
dollars the expo makes 10
on that because it's on the ledger
forever in perpetuity there is a royalty
in the contract that is very different
than issuing a ticket not only that
it's marketing when maha who will do
this in 20 years
if you know maha meet somebody important
or famous or
influential today when we meet somebody
we look at google
and we look at instagram to see who they
are after they leave oh that person was
interesting let me look them up right
yeah we all do it
i believe in five years we will also
look at maha's public
wallet to see what tokens she has and
when i look in there and see that she
has
four years worth of going to the art
festival or the film festival
right you know in egypt or or world expo
that will be marketing towards me wow
this interesting person that i think is
cool and is accomplished
they go every year to this art expo i
want to go to the art expo there was no
way to do what i just said
five years ago exactly there might be a
photo that you put on instagram
that says you're here but by the time i
meet you four years later
i'm not seeing that photo whereas the
public wallet
will become a social currency layer so
what the expo just did by not issuing a
boring
qr code ticket or a paper ticket by
doing an nft is they've created a
collectible variable that can be
marketing but it is also a financial
impact on them because as that token
continues to trade
then all of a sudden they're making
money in perpetuity i love it gary thank
you i want to talk about your project
last but not least
so garyvee nfts are launching on may 5th
we've been talking a lot about it trying
to educate everybody about how to create
a wallet and how to do it but tell us
about your project why are you
launching your own nfts the same reason
i launched winelibrary.com and wine
library tv
internet was foreign to me computers
were foreign to me
yet i knew the internet was going to
change the world so the only way i knew
i would learn is by having a website
hencewinelibrary.com
in 2005 i realized that social media and
content were about to change the world
on the internet and so the only thing i
knew to do was to and i never
appeared in any video i never had
aspirations to be a public figure
i was 30 years old and i was a retailer
i was a businessman
and so i started wine library tv because
i needed to taste it
i needed to know how to use youtube and
twitter and myspace and facebook to
drive business
the reason i'm doing a project is nfts
are now the third moment in my career
internet one internet two and now
internet three wet or web
3.0 and so i have to launch my own
project
so that i can advise invest and
communicate
around this technology i get my hands
dirty which is where my insights come
from
that's why i have to do it and is it
available to everybody in the middle
east to be able to purchase your nfts
it is you have to get a custodial wallet
obviously different wallets
over index in different parts of the
world you need to have ethereum
in that wallet and then you have to be
able to get your own non-custodial
wallet connect has a lot of them and
then the one that i'm most recommending
because it's the one i use and it's
easiest in my opinion
metamask because it has a chrome
extension that makes it very easy that
is available to everybody and
that would be the route to go and why
should somebody buy your nft
i saw you we were saying the other day
about this is a blueprint for how to do
nfts
the real reason i believe that most
people should buy my nft is
my obsession with making it a valuable
outcome for them you know look nfts are
high risk
you know i've said it over and over i
believe 98 of nft projects right now are
not good investments
now if you love an artist if you love an
athlete or musician you want to support
them like a t-shirt muzzle top that's
exactly right
but for me my focus is treating this as
a 45-year project
not a 45-day project i think i see some
people with big audiences treating this
as a four-hour project you know to me
this is not a
money grab or a land grab and i you know
i don't want to give away too much but i
think it will be very clear
when i launched this the inherent value
of the smart contract
should dramatically outpace the original
investment made by people
gary i'm so excited for 5'5 we can't
wait to
see it and i'm excited for anyone in
middle east who has questions dm me
we're gonna help you guys understand
nfts and about the industry in general
thank you gary for your time today
appreciate it
thanks maha happy ramadan everyone yeah
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you